ich glaube da stehe ich
auf wanderer bin ich schon oft abgang
für büro und haben gefragt was dahinter
steckt
seine kommunen versteckt und aufpasst
uhr mit dem tüv weniger immer wieder
begegnet die neugier und faszination
immer größer wurde ist auch ein
gefahrenpunkt programm musik verbunden
gc der schweiz viele vor der
militärische bunkeranlage um zweiter und
sogenannte halter gebaut wurde sind wir
vom militär braucht die meister wartet
still kleid und einige davon sind jetzt
sind private haben
wunder was sind das für lytro privatbank
besitzt und was machen sie damit
für die reportage die faszinierende welt
vor der schweizer geschichte
[Musik]
minute mit der superlative ich bin auf
dem weg zum grössten banken der schweiz
wo in privatbesitz ist er befindet sich
da überhaupt was im kanton st gallen die
ehemalige militärische anlage ist im
privatbesitz von erich breiter muss
[Musik]
ich fahre mit dem auto innerhalb
dorf mit 105 98 km lang und das
wasserreservoir für 1,8 millionen liter
wasser 600 soldaten hat für das halbjahr
im notfall schutz kann mit dem auto wird
sagen und zwar man ewig unterwegs trumpf
ist der elektro der fliegt gerade
mit
wer wie gott ist das dahinter ja
kilometer bis in
nordrhein-westfalen minute lang einfach
gang hinter und aber wissen wir dann im
unteren stock auch mit wo mir der ehre
die wichtigsten room zeigt und ihre
geschichte erzählt
wichtig ist vor dem zweiten weltkrieg
gebaut wurde und wann kaut ich noch mal
erweitert modernisiert und atom sicher
gemacht wurde
nie zu achten inst ist ein still kleid
wurde und 2002 ästhetik entlang wurde
der ich zeig mir nur jene steht wieder
die
liebschaft sonntag der
unterhalt 1503 partie ganz allein 500
für jede einzelne ruhe herrscht und
schlüssel müssen wir seinen schlüssel zu
hören
der stadtteil ist
aber was ist ihre motivation dass das so
eine feste kraft
seit die säge zum kaufen und den
symbologen aber direkt so ein riesending
man sieht haber
direktorin des kaufvertrages kaufen und
über sehr wichtig und aber kommerziell
kann mir bist du das machen wir
natürlich nutzen besteht zum lokal das
möglichkeit lütge für lager crypto
mining services und so weiter das
operieren und nicht
langfristig an der sicherheit des teams
machen will man 100 schiffen ins grün
und über 30 quadratmeter brauchbare
fläche der heißt möglichkeit in sachen
machen
der erde vermieter triumphierte crypto
mining serverraum lager für whisky wodka
zur spezielles gravitations experiment
macht und platz hat man so viel mehr
zwei tage der woche ist da sticht wann
fliegt sache und installiert aber
unterhalb der
wolke in szenekreisen kratzen da macht
da nur die feuerwehr sich fragen kann es
um die
familien bisher ein projekt spritzt die
fahrer bereiten sich frankreichs ist ein
kübel kosten 50 frankreich spezielle
kalkar größten glauben die abläufe
mimose bezogen und das ganze strom zu
stehen hatte bricht das sams team war
das andere kollegen
erich machte offiziell registriert im
untergrund des biz hervor wie er gut
vergangenheit
die ganze praktischen spital tiere
vertragen so weiter könnte zumal
dahinter mehr ist die selbst stück
strahler und strom produziert der
blackout gibt man alles aufgeht oder
sozialer dieser motor für schiffsmotoren
und das ist nicht immer
hightech und low tech wie viel der ehre
für den bunker zahlt wetter netz ag
verratet mir aber dass der bunker vor 80
jahren zwei millionen franken gekostet
und zitaten nur uv die der widrig
steckte
in der zwischenzeit hat der mieter das
mannschafts kontinent dahin ist kochen
auf witches mit zum teil auf den bunker
und absurd das
unterdorf und
das hat mich unglaublich
dass das ist ja nur
also mega mega mega faszinierend
das echtzeit schnell das sind alles
meitinger und das schon liftschacht
hätte ich mir das
jetzt wieder im opferstock
david nauer hätte es gar das kino
praktika und coach und spürte mit
immobilien gemacht die alle mir dir
ehrlich zeigt mackey extreme faszination
ist aber vollkommen nachvollziehen aber
gerade ganz die alte
so wird
sie unter den edition praktisch szene
hatte
machten macht andrews notvorrat einen
anteil machen dass wir zusammen
luftschutzkeller notvorrat und sondern
fasziniere oder video von 80 euro
besonderheiten jetzt containerbau wo
ohne computer typisch spitzenpolitik und
dann meistens noch erhalten also stück
schweizer geschichte stand der schweizer
geschichte um die hamburger bereits im
alter finanziell und zugleich
möglichkeit blut gegeben die sache
machen wie zum beispiel haben zu widmen
oder sicherheitslage oder zu üben und je
nach dem abi gemacht dass ich für
leitstelle sieht es für zehn euro kann
ohne werbung von uns vertrauen können
unser recht nämlich sie keine ahnung und
die stehen da alles vorhanden aber du
darfst du dich jetzt nächsten wonach
es ist gemacht wenn sie mich als bundes
haben für die sie im bundesamt für
zivilschutz wunder in den
luftschutzkeller den künstlichen koma
aber gib dir das auch wenn das viel für
sicherheits dass das hier keine pixel
selbst passiert
sieht dem projekt da sämtliche telefon
303 wende bringen
die angst und die kraft haben
deutschland und
natürlich
bloß wenn die katharinen trauen der
anlage und egal wie eine familie
runterbringen
absolut
box die kanone geschossen 12
die granate 240 kg
c max bruch zum die kanone wie die ihnen
bisher schönste minuten
sogar nach hause geflogen
das notausgangs
sitzt dahinter sind da
krone.at die kanone und gerade getan
ich kann einfach nicht anders als
student allem wo man drauf gefahren alle
sind zwar um sechs jahr in keiner
gesprächsgruppe und bald wurde und dass
die musik auch die anderen anlagen
verteilt diesen ganzen land diesmal hat
man die gefahr ist eine adrette und
verteidigen
es ist einfach so mega mega glücklich so
erfasst ich einfach in privatbesitz und
man fragt sich jetzt sicher ja einfach
jede person wahrt seine lisa versucht
auf der erich enorme damals im bunker
direkt von privat kauft die ihr personal
ihn aber vorher vom militär abkam und
dafür zuständig ist armasuisse wo zum
vbs gehört die sind dafür zuständig für
alle stilllegung und für alle verkäufe
aller bürger über die website schrieben
sie jährlich 120 bunker und gebäude von
militärs und wir werden den teams
spielten stationen verkauft gaben hat
die mit armasuisse weil er persönlich
stellung nahm vor der kamera die
verantwortlichen nicht wähle gar dafür
aber per mail also das wissen wir jetzt
folgendes geschrieben sie sagt dass bis
jetzt 1800 militärische anlage verkauft
wurde sind
4701 is still kleid und 500 sind
rückgebaut wurde jetzt planen sie
weitere
musik 500 bunker stets lecker jetzt
kommt das große aber viele vor einer
bunker von einer strickleiter punkte
wird mehrmals rainer verkauft waren
werden krugs oder ganze sache sind
nämlich die verschiedenen bauzonen
ehemalige militär arbeitet sonst prozent
nicht in ihrer wohnung in der street
ohne und bewilligung zum zonen und man
nur sehr selten so bliebt armee obwohl
sie die ganze weile verkaufen ein großer
teil vorlage sitze
vor zehn jahren holten punkt findet hier
das jetzt so viel einfach nur umstand
bezirk swiss einfach irgendwo in bangkok
hätte sind und viele vereine wohl nicht
verkraftet die stadt jetzt einfach um
und ich einen tipp vom büro das funknetz
megawatt wachsen
aufgewacht einfach so ohne start und ich
habe es mit chris und ich bin jetzt
gehört
zu einem gang vor dem bunker schon
irgendwie komisch zum dank das jetzt die
straßen zu verlaufen dass
die bank risiken für der bunker im fels
oder irgendwo im wald
baut wurde nicht natürlich glaubt ein
stetiger
[Musik]
für die lage und verlassenheit wo der
ort ausstrahlt zusammen mit mama an der
wand und mehr lateinische sprichwort
wenn du frieden willst bereite krieg vor
und
[Musik]
können wir eigentlich nur mal schnell
über taster da redet
also diese haus statt einfach nur wann
was soll das hat er bei christa sich
humer ich das jetzt richtig sehen ist
eis artillerie
loch
okay das ist zu betonieren
mithilfe oder drohnen findet es schade
aber ich kann alles entdeckt rom heran
und macht mit unwiderruflicher war ob
es so faszinierend wie das jetzige sich
irgendwie anders
ist so ein verlassener ort ist so
schmutzig ist
alles jahres hinterland die eigene sache
ist das gefühl vor ist eigentlich gar
nicht so dass ich gar nicht wissen die
haie im internet finde dass die
artillerie ursprung heißt und 1940
bebaut worden ist siehe da 25 cm kann
ohne die acht meter breite masse
torhüter stand von 15 jahre ist sie aber
still kleid und rückgebaut wurde noch
was ich jetzt zu recht fragen
vor der wahl politischer lag und wenn er
zur anlage zur musik fachstelle kleid
und verkauft waren sie mir als
bevölkerung überhaupt noch gut geschützt
und wird völlig mit sinn mache
wenigstens einige anlage wieder in
betrieb nahm und auf das ende von swiss
aua angeschrieben und sie mal nicht dass
die meisten für eine militärische anlage
schon über 80 jahre alt sind also das
wird schlicht was sinn mehr machen weil
die sind so veraltet und entsprechend
gar nicht erst wird einer modernen armee
und wieder sagt sie dass die ganze
anlage sowieso auch nicht für
zivilbevölkerung dank sind für den
zivilschutz zuständig und im ganzen land
über
370.000 zivilschutzbunker wo platz für
über neun millionen personen also da
immer mehr als genug platz und schutz
für jede und jeden 5 alex ich darf mich
mit einer ihrer prunksitzung am alex
lustig
nicht nur eine sondern
für sein bild sucht einen stadtplan mit
walter sieht fünf jahren züchtet er die
mittlerweile im bunker für ihn viele
vorteile bringt
lg neckar-enz klima wohl schon
betrachten ist und dass ich meistens
vertraut und dunkel das heißt jetzt wie
faktor je nachdem was ich
machen muss schon trocken
frischluft maschine pumpe oder das toben
bringen das heißt das muss angst haben
sehr strenge bevor es funktioniert ich
habe das buch nicht aber ich habe gerade
mein vater zusammen zu sehen zwölf
weitere punkte erspielte sich
mitarbeiter am pilz amtes sind
die bunker wo gerade aber der autobahn
richtig gut tat stand ein zu armee zieht
aus bühl lager und druckerei die
mitarbeiter wenn diese aber definitiv
nicht erwartet
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
so
wie der graben
das spezielle wo sich 40 tage da besser
machte es kurz wachstum wurde dieter
kremer wohl sicher berechtigt mit dem
wunderbaren tage bis monate mitarbeiter
je nach größe es richtig stadium
handkante panik anders als im erich
stopp im alex mit faszination für die
besondere gabe aus dem foto und sondern
nutzer
unbedingt ja
das ist
sehr praktisch sie aber das ist nicht
ganz ohne sie uns nutzen gewiss ist
dass die munition gelagert wurde nicht
bevor die rede hobby biolebensmittel
produzent
reststoffe sind belastet ohne chance und
das überall oder wie viel material für
wahnsinnig ganze stadt entsprachen oder
und das hat mit profi-fußball so das
objekt diesmal ein tisch das auch in der
industrie
das haben wir aber die messen um zone
wie
wichtig
dichter wie ist das gemeint
antrag stellen und damals gemeint
bewilligen
natürlich habe ich es ja
so was ja
eigentlich ist ein schönes gefühl dass
die burg gebucht werden einerseits
historisch dass der platz nicht ganz
verschwindet ist und erhält alle anderen
die es sind einfach im park aber was ist
wenn ich sage dass ich fehler der
frieden schweiz gebäude geht wo ein
bunker sind aber wir normale user und
schüler aus gesehen waren meine
recherche die namen oft an die bunker
gestoßen im dörfli st margrethen berg
oberhalb von bad ragaz stand vor einer
wiese verteilt und die können alle
nutzer festivals und bunker von erich zu
verbieten es wäre normal agatha in
normale schüler was auf der wiese statt
aber wenn man möglich und das ist
einfach so pathetisch und da hat der
hirte und sich alles so rundum also idee
minderheits mehrere geschütz über new
music verteidigungs buy outs in der
schweiz wie viel vor deiner also tanz
sind kann mit armasuisse aber nicht
genau sagen
tag seiner kommunen und versteckten und
tante
lustig
sie hatte im ernstfall für das ganze
land recherchiert die fast jedem kanton
stand sie getarnt die bunker sowie
oberhalb von glarus im ortenberger ganz
normal physisches landschaftsbild ihm
wirklich schnell wie das wasser wurde
stand die sind so gut fand einer ist
dahin gehört hinter mir und dazu zwei
wieder dahin
insgesamt stand 8 stück da über diese
verteilt geraden aber bruderhof und
bewohnte häuser
[Musik]
mit dem tüv machen mit einem ass letzte
werk von glados ufer zum ford kapazität
stadt nahm nerb skurriler bunker mit in
der landschaft
[Musik]
so wird auf dem vorplatz
der letzte teil von andermatt letzter
oper ist einfach noch mal krass ihr seid
einfach links und rechts in berlin
überaus starken punkt an die bunker und
du bist davon wie quanta punkte punkte
punkte der letzte woche ich jetzt noch
mal zeigen dass chemie das finde ich
ziemlich speziell einfach weil er so alt
ist und er ist irgendwo da jetzt also
ich glaube das ist das ist ein schönes
fuß
der bunker ist teil von der krise heftig
56 02 41 gebaut wurden ist gefestigt hat
platz für 400 mark diversität an die
kanone stand auf der vision und
verschiedene anti panzer dürrn
[Musik]
bunkeranlage in der schweiz erforscht
vergassen die unterwelt einige der fotos
von der 2 doch die meister stand einfach
auszieht züge vom krieg unzählige im
land zur landesverteidigung aber damals
gefühlt jeder partner aushöhlen
was bleibt sind einige kamlage war auch
heute noch braucht wartet und wie das
bild von der schweiz aus fest ich habe
ganz ehrlich ich könnte jetzt nur 500
weitere bunker zeiger die reportage
betriebsstunde und man hat immer noch
nicht alles gesehen es gab einfach nur
so viel mehr zum zeigen zum 3 es ist
einfach ich finde dafür einfach so
spannend für mich längst hat sich zwar
gewundert was findet ihr vor der
thematik sind vielleicht auch schon
getan der bunker für bücher findet ihr
neben ungenutzten erwartet also findet
einfach allgemein ja man hat halt die
bunker gebaut und das
schiebe ich mir unbedingt der fall
kommentar und für mehr so reportage
abonnieren